es ist die Hymne für die Proteste im
Iran baraye Herr der iranische Musiker
sherwin Hashi pur hat den Protestsong
der das müller-regime kritisiert
komponiert wurde zum Mega Hit der
Musiker wurde festgenommen und jetzt
diese Szenen diese
Gänsehautmomente Coldplay bei ihrem
Konzert in Buenos Aires ein mega Zeichen
des dort gesetzt ja und sie spielen eben
genau diesen Song ein wirklicher
Gänsehautmoment ja von Schwerin wurde
dann sogar noch mit seinem Video zum
Song eingeblendet ein ganz starkes
Zeichen was ihr gesetzt
[Musik]
und sie geben nicht auf im Iran wird
trotz Drohungen des mularisims weiter
mutig auf die Straße gegangen und auch
hier in Deutschland doch hier in Berlin
kam es jetzt zu einem brutalen Angriff
vor der iranischen Botschaft
brutaler Attacke auf Iran Demonstranten
mitten in Berlin mitten in der Nacht
vier Teilnehmer einer Mahnwache wurden
in der Nacht zu Sonntag geschlagen
getreten und mit einem Messer verletzt
herausgeholt und mich angegriffen mein
linker Fuß wurde verletzt als ich
versucht habe mich zu verteidigen und
ihm das Messer wegzunehmen von hinten
wurde ich auf den Kopf und in die Rippe
geschlagen
gegen eine 15 ging der Alarm bei der
Polizei ein ein Mitarbeiter des
zentralen Objektschutzes hatte gegenüber
der iranischen Botschaft in Berlin
Dahlem bemerkt wie drei vermummte
transparente und Fahnen von einem
Wohnwagen rissen nachdem der Mitarbeiter
des objektsschutzes die Polizei gerufen
hatte forderte er die randaliere auf
ihre Tat zu unterlassen vergeblich
fünf Personen befanden sich im Wohnwagen
nachdem sie rauskamen wurden sie sofort
von den drei Angreifern attackiert vier
der fünf Demonstranten wurden verletzt
mit Messerstichen Schlägen und hoher
Gewalt
am leukämaschine
als ich das Kennzeichen aufschreiben
wollte sind die hinteren Türen
aufgegangen und mir wurde eine Pistole
ins Gesicht gehalten aus Angst habe ich
mich hinter einem Baum auf dem Boden
versteckt alle fünf Angreifer sind dann
weggefahren
Maschine die verletzten Männer kamen zur
ambulanten Behandlung in ein Krankenhaus
die Angreifer sollen unmittelbar nach
den Attacken in einen auf der
gegenüberliegenden Straßenseite
wartenden PKW gestiegen und davon gerast
sein der Staatsschutz hat die
Ermittlungen aufgenommen
[Musik]